tras días de incertidumbre los analistas
militares ya están seguros la
contraofensiva ucraniana ha comenzado el
kremlin ha publicado Este vídeo afirma
que las columnas de tanques y vehículos
blindados pertenecen a kiev se dice que
han intentado recuperar terreno en el
sur antes de ser bombardeados Vladimir
Putin habló de la operación en curso en
el contexto de una visita Sochi
como ya he dicho desde hace cinco días
se libran intensos combates por ejemplo
ayer y anteayer fueron días Muy intensos
pero el enemigo no ha tenido éxito en
ninguno de los sectores
en este mapa del ministerio francés de
las fuerzas armadas se puede ver que las
zonas de combate están dispersas por el
sureste una estrategia para probar las
líneas de defensas rusas y luego atacar
con mayor eficacia está en el corazón de
los combates en las calles de la ciudad
los ucranianos expresan su apoyo a esta
contraofensiva tan esperada
quiero que echen a los rusos lo antes
posible para que podamos reanudar
nuestra vida como antes
el presidente boladimir selensky sigue
una estrategia que lleva semanas en
marcha en sus declaraciones diarias no
mencionan ninguna contraofensiva Ni
operación específica
para nuestros soldados para todos
aquellos que están participando en
combates especialmente difíciles estos
días vemos su heroísmo y les estamos
agradecidos por cada minuto de su vida
el pasado fin de semana el ministro de
defensa ucraniano publicó en las redes
sociales este video enigmático en el que
los soldados con los dedos delante de la
boca parecen pedir silencio total